pues sí y es que aunque normalmente
debería ser una cita anual como bien
dices en la última vez que se celebró
fue en 2015 y por qué pues porque en
estos años han pasado muchas cosas
primero que estas debates no se suelen
celebrar en año electoral o cuando hay
elecciones generales cercanas y es que
desde 2016 ha habido tres elecciones
generales en españa además ha habido dos
mociones de censura una intento de
declaración unilateral por parte de
cataluña en 2017 y como bien sabemos en
2020 llegó la pandemia de kobe 19 que ha
impedido que se celebre durante 2020 y
2021 durante estos años ha cambiado el
liderazgo del gobierno como bien decías
es la primera vez que pedro sánchez
lidera este debate de ley sobre el
estado de la nación como presidente del
ejecutivo un discurso que ha durado una
hora y veinte en la que ha anunciado
algunas medidas para paliar los efectos
de la inflación sobre la clase
trabajadora española él ha dicho que el
gobierno se va a dejar la piel para
ayudar a estos nacionales entre estas
medidas
por ciento de los abonos de transporte
para los trenes de cercanías o de media
distancia hasta diciembre desde
septiembre y también las medidas que más
aplausos se han llevado han sido los
impuestos a los beneficios caídos del
cielo como dicen a las grandes
eléctricas y también a los bancos unas
medidas que recaudan unos 3500 millones
de euros para el estado ahora manera le
pregunto cómo llega el gobierno de
españa' a esta cita parlamentaria
pues llega tras los impactos
precisamente de esta pandemia de kobe
durante el 2020 y el 2021 también el
estallido la erupción del volcán en la
palma que ha dejado muchos daños y
desperfectos la guerra en ucrania y sus
consecuencias como por ejemplo una
inflación desbocada en españa que
alcanza el 10,2 por ciento
además escándalos de espionaje a los
miembros de partidos independentistas
catalanes y recordemos que es este es un
gobierno de coalición como bien tú
decías en los titulares este gobierno de
coalición ha tenido varios varias crisis
varias desavenencias en concreto por
temas como el apoyo de más dinero para
presupuesto militar o las desavenencias
que ha habido por ejemplo con cómo
reaccionó el gobierno ante el sáhara
occidental y en estas últimas semanas
con los incidentes en la frontera en
melilla con las decenas de migrantes
muertos así que varios retos para el
presidente del gobierno pero por ahora
ha recibido bastantes aplausos y el
partido de coalición 'unidos podemos
más' reaccionado bastante positivamente
a los anuncios que ha hecho este en
pedro sánchez